il faut avait pas coutume on commence
par le sport pour dépasser ce cars de
supporters d'anderlecht et les envoyer
directement dans faut c'est rester assis
une chemise norme nc possibles écoutes à
plus 14 ans tout de même
les nouvelles et les elle commence tout
de suite je suis à martin je suis milou
je suis le moniteur c'est quoi les
cuissons standard de liège bien sûr mais
le football sinon vous avez quelques
notions de conduite
ah oui je conduis souvent surtout quand
je suis bourré vous y connaissez en
musique
vous n'êtes pas que supporters de foot
alors bon dieu va nous donner ce soir
est ce que c'est moi je n'ai pas
beaucoup de conversation c'est que vous
faites ce soir est logé des places pour
don si on gagne on revient sur les deux
premières non ce soir c'est pas possible
ma mère est malade attention donc tu
veux tuer nos femmes victoire victoire
du standard 3 0 si bien avec toi
je passe ma mère m'aime dis pas qu'on va
pas au stade où tu veux que j'aille
restaurer non mr nouveaux malades
oui
pour remplacer le mot inconnu par la
mouffe football as tu déjà essayé
d'arrêter de consommer du football sans
y parvenir
oui j'ai à perdre et de relation
affective à cause de ta consommation de
football
oui je suis footballeur
saloperie toxico la débarrasse de tout
ce qui touche aux dames mulhouse en
train de changer
c'est pas la peine de me rappeler partir
de maintenant n'existe plus un match
toujours très attendu entre 1 ces deux
équipes choisissent de se concentrer
tout moment fils prend son élan trahir
le standard jour au lendemain